When I write these film analysis,
I usually start by watching the film
with a notepad and writing down all the
things I think are interesting.
When I started watching long car wise in
the mood for love,
the first thing I wrote was five minutes
in and every shot is a frame within a
frame,
meaning that every single shot feature
characters not only framed by the
rectangle of the film itself,
but by smaller internal shapes as well,
and this is the visual technique that
filmmakers have used for decades.
My favorite example is the great last
shot and John Ford's masterpiece,
the searchers,
but seldom is it used so ubiquitously as
the film went on.
I had to cross out five from my little
note and change it to six,
seven,
nine.
It wasn't until minute 12 that I saw the
first shot without some foreground
obstruction.
This shot,
which crucially doesn't feature either
of the two main characters,
but wait,
I'm getting ahead of myself in the mood
for love is the story of two married
couples who happened to rent rooms in
the adjacent homes of older couples in
19 sixties.
Hong Kong.
The film focuses on the husband of one
couple Mr Chow and the wife of the other
Mrs.
Chan,
as they both gradually discover that
their spouses are cheating on them with
each other and then how those two
innocent victims of infidelity come
together to deal with the pain of that.
The film manages to be unsentimental
with its subject matter while couching
the events in sumptuous painterly
cinematography.
The narrative skips and jumps forward
through time at an erratic speed,
as one might recall.
The story in memory and the viewer is
often left initially confused as to how
much time has passed between scenes.
This prompts a strong engagement with
the film,
a need to pay attention,
but it also reflects how the film was
made.
There was a little more than an outline
when long car why and his crew began
filming a process that took a long,
15 months in which the script and the
individual scenes were written on the
fly by the director and the actors
together.
Which is surprising because watching the
film,
you can't help but feel that you're in
the hands of somebody in complete
control visually and emotionally.
In the mood for love is fully
consistent,
the film is so self contained that it
only features a handful of locations
each filmed from the same angle so that
you experience a kind of circular effect
of returning again and again to the same
things.
This technique far from feeling sluggish
or repetitive,
instead isolates against fixed backwards
the things that actually are changing in
the film,
the inner lives of the two leads and for
the most part these inner lives are
explored worthless.
The real action of this movie is in
posture glances,
touches by restricting the language.
One car.
Why echoes the restriction of action
that plagues Mr.
Chow and Mrs Chan in 19 sixties,
Hong Kong,
where they are under constant threat of
gossip,
kind of surveillance from their
landlords and the community at large,
the CCC,
but this is one reason why everything is
doubly framed by placing objects in the
foreground.
The director enhances the feeling that
the characters have of being observed,
not to mention our own feelings of being
observers observed and observing,
seen and being seen what we desire from
others,
what others desire from us.
These are major themes of in the mood
for love.
I think the most extraordinary element
of this film is what's introduced just
after the two main characters admit to
each other that their spouses are
cheating instead of confronting the
situation head on,
their primary goal becomes to understand
exactly how it happened,
so we get this incredible scene where
they reenact the seduction of their
spouses in which each attempt to embody
the spouse of the other while being
coached by the other on what they think
the spouse really would or wouldn't do.
This makes for a really complex but also
kind of perverse interplay,
though the film aggressively focuses on
only Mr.
Chow and Mrs Chan to the point of never
even showing the faces of their spouses
were always aware that for people not to
are involved here,
but it's not for real people.
It's two people and two phantoms.
I think of what's being asked of Chow
and Chan in the seduction scene.
In the guise of understanding what
happened.
Each victim attempts to seduce their own
spouse in the form of the other's
spouse.
A task.
It has to be doomed from the start
because the fact of the affair itself
means that neither child nor chan can
any longer elicit that kind of desire
that they're trying to recreate.
You could describe this course of action
as masochistic and one car.
Why lets us feel this by not making it
obvious when Mr Chow or Mrs Chan are
being themselves or being each other's
spouses often were admitted into the
scene,
interpreting it one way before the
reality or perhaps the unreality of the
moment hits us like a gut punch,
but because each player is constantly
coaching the other,
they're able to construct fantasy in
which they control their own betrayal
and by never consummating their own
butting love for each other.
Mr.
Chow and Mrs Chan can infinitely delay
the moment in which they have to see
things as they really are.
They can stay in their fantasy.
It's a tragic and twisted state of
affairs and one car wide has said that
if Tony Young and Maggie Chung weren't
such beautiful actors,
the darkness at the center of their
characters and their fantasy would be
obvious.
Of course they can't keep it up forever
and in the scene where Mr Chow finally
admits his love for Mrs Chin,
most of the fantasy comes crumbling down
as he says,
they are like their spouses,
which means that the thing they've been
refusing to see,
their own lack,
that they've ceased to be an object of
love for their loved one rushes into
consciousness like a wave and yet still
they don't act on it,
can only let the brutal truth in so much
in order to survive.
In order to move forward,
Mr.
Chow and Mrs Chan doom themselves to
missed connections.
This is why at the end,
the film jumps forward to see them just
missing each other twice,
just missing each other.
The mere possibility of a connection.
The connection itself is what sustains
them.
Now,
everybody lives within fantasy within
frames.
Sometimes the frames are made by us.
Sometimes they're made by others.
Sometimes we need to believe that those
made by us are made by others,
but whatever the case,
there is no way out of the frame when
fantasies rupture or crack or break down
completely.
That's trauma,
like living temporarily in a storm,
one car wise in the mood for love is a
gorgeous,
quiet and painful exploration of what
happens when the fantasy you create for
yourself is a perverse one when it only
serves to keep you from confronting the
pain and it was created to avoid.
And the reason the film is so
heartbreaking is because this kind of
perversity is really quite common to all
of this.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed it.
God,
I love this movie.
If you think that the nerd writer is
something that you're not seeing
anywhere else on youtube and you want to
help support,
it helped me keep putting the time and
effort it takes to make videos like
this.
Um,
you can pledge to my patrion page.
That will be awesome.
You guys have been amazing.
Um,
and every little thing helps.
You can click here right now to do that
as little as $1.
Thanks again and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already,
to get all these videos and stay tuned
for some really cool stuff coming up.
Some cool collaborations coming up and
here are some more videos.